time now for what to watch and neither
snow
nor rain nor gloom of night can keep
vlad duty from his appointed rounds i
don't know if i can say that about the
united states postal service right now
vlad
but it's good to see you and i know
you're gonna be here for us
what do you have today good to see you
we try to deliver uh just like our mail
carriers in fact during the pandemic i
would always tip my hat
to our mail carrier that we saw here
because she was the only one the only
person that we saw throughout the
hardest points of the pandemic here in
new york city so we
tip our hats to our mail carriers across
the country good to see all of you back
in the studio
and you tony at home uh while we are
here working from home still it's been
over a hundred
broadcasts we're checking out a few
stories we think you'll be talking about
today so a week after a deadly wind
storm slammed iowa people across the
state are still
having trouble the damage from that
duratio is
unreal many buildings were reduced to
rubble and crop fields were leveled
nearly 76 000 utility customers still
don't have any power people say they are
desperate for help
no matter who you are you can do
something and cedar rapids and other
small towns in iowa they need your help
we're regular working people we need
help down here
and the only help we're getting is from
each other
this direction has really been deadly
iowa governor kim reynolds called
on the white house to declare disaster
there as soon as possible she is asking
the federal government
for nearly 4 billion dollars in a tony
nearly 14 million acres of farmland have
been destroyed this is a real important
story
yeah i know it really is vlad and what
reminds me is that while we talk about
the coronavirus of course that's a
national effect a global disaster
all the other regular disasters that you
would expect in a given year
related to weather or fire those are
still going on and we've got to pay
attention to those as well